you mentioned earlier that you saw
Warren Beatty and Annette Bening on a
red carpet yes volunteering and you took
the liberty to go up and just honor
their work and say hello but you said
sometimes you go back and forth
sometimes that extrovert you comes out
and sometimes introvert comes out and I
think a lot of actors have them inside
of them they get really in their heads
how does it have to promote themselves
when they don't want to come off
shamelessly promoting themselves but
then they know that that's part of their
job and especially if they're not
represented right you've done a
wonderful job in creating worth your son
can without that which you should be
really proud of something how how do you
thatis that actor get out of their head
and and get out of that introverted kind
of anti-social mode it is really hard to
sell yourself especially when you're the
product it's a really good question and
it's like got so many dynamics to it um
I think we're all start is when I made
the switch from I had mentioned to you
guys i booked a lot of bands when I
first moved to town and when I made that
switch to what are you doing you're
promoting everyone else's career and not
yourself and your talents I made that
switch I suddenly realized like oh my
god I know how to promote everyone else
but I don't know how to promote me like
I was used to putting out email blasts
all the time about this band in that
band and they're doing a video shoot and
they've got a concert and come on down
and see this awesome sexy guy you know
whatever it was but I didn't know how to
say like great come Celia yeah or like I
check out what I'm doing and I also i
think had a big wake-up call as to the
fact that everybody was just used to me
promoting all their stuff and it was
hard to like make that switch happens
like no no no I've got stuff that I want
to posts on my own myspace page right
now you know that kind of thing um so
it's definitely a lifelong process I
think but then there's obviously a
finesse to it you know there's obviously
a way to do it now I didn't go up to
Warren internet on the carpet I
approached them at the party afterwards
the carpet would be really I think would
be really awkward because those actors
are you know they're posing for photos
and stuff like that you always have to
feel it out like each situation is
completely different here's a good one
here's a good one at that same event
Christian Slater was there and Christian
and I have both worked on Robot Chicken
we don't know each other but we've both
worked on robot chicken and then I saw
him I'm trying to think I'm not sure if
i have it backwards or not yeah okay and
then I did a spot on my name is earl i
don't know six months late or something
like that and he was the guest star and
I had this extra roll bumped into a
featured spot where I was singing a song
next to him and he actually ends up
handing me you know one of the props
like I was like hey you want to hand to
me and we did we had this little acting
moment together so now i'm at this
premiere and Christians walking down the
red carpet at me and my friend are like
walking this way and do it and she's
like didn't you just do some work with
him and I'm like you know so then we get
in line to get the popcorn he's in line
next to us again and she's like no all
right so now we finally going to walk to
our seats and just at that moment he
happens to be walking back up with
another gentleman and I'm like all right
universe you're telling me to like don't
let the cat have your tongue and say
something that this man i was like
christian hey my name's Leah we worked
on one about chicken together and we
just didn't episode of my name is earl
because i thought you looked familiar
introduces me to his manager so guys my
manager you know good to see you you
know that was it you know but if i run
into him again down the line now it's
like a familiar face it's like oh hey
and so we can't be afraid to approach
people in this industry whether it's
Steven Spielberg or JJ Abrams or you
know Warren Beatty and Annette Bening
because they're just human beings too
and they probably if you're interesting
maybe maybe they want to know you
new home and give you like us you have
something to share with this world right
like that's why we do what we do so if
you can't tell anybody about it then
you're sitting in your basement
somewhere um so I think there's any
there's times there's times where I
won't approach somebody or like I'm
trying to feel at that right moment and
it doesn't happen but maybe I talked
myself out of it i'm not sure um i wish
i had a chance to talk to leonardo
dicaprio and and and I took it and you
know I you know approached him first by
complimenting him on all the charity
work that he does and what not and and
then we got a little conversation going
about Twitter and project i was in and
stuff like that and he walked away and
like the entire sports where I was like
oh my gosh you just talk to Leah hired
Heather and I was like well yeah I was
telling him about my work about my
project you know like I think as a whole
we want to know what our fellow human
beings are doing especially if it aligns
with something that you're doing but
then of course that goes into the online
world of promotion which is tricky I
personally I post a lot I post a lot and
tweet a lot but I do it on my own page
so i have a strict policy that i don't
like it when someone posts something on
my facebook page that i didn't ask you
to post that i'm not connected to that
I'm not involved in somehow um because
that's my space you know like these
people are subscribed to what I'm doing
because for some reason or another
either they feel feel guilty and
connected for the care about what I'm
doing and so if somebody happens to stop
by you know Karen's page they should see
some of the latest of what Karen's doing
not what Billy and Joey and Bobby are
doing because they posted on your page I
sometimes feel as taking advantage of
like somebody else's bulletin board so
to speak you know um a girlfriend of
mine Robin she's a writer in New York
she put it this way a long time ago and
it stuck with me ever since I have to
Facebook pages which has any kind of
entertainer performer i highly recommend
you do want the smaller page where your
friends and your family are ya that gets
a little lower at a time but then you
need that professional page that doesn't
cap limit on it and that you only post
professional things not the photo of you
and your kitty when you wake up in the
morning cuz i do it too um there does
need to be a boundary but my friend
Robin had mentioned that accepting
people unlike your Facebook page is sort
of like giving them a backstage pass to
your life not everybody gets a backstage
pass at the poison concert you know what
I mean not everybody does so I'm
selective and so there's been your sale
just to leave it if it happens again
I'll deleted and I'll say something I've
run into a few cases people that I was
friends with for ten years where they're
like recently a guy I knew who was
promoting his new web show yet had never
looked at mine or you know any of that
stuff um I said hey you know that's kind
of spammy you know he didn't get it and
he accused me of not caring about him
and not caring it but his career deleted
me out facebook I don't like I I wrote a
couple blogs I write for a blog called
talk nerdy to me love her and I did a
couple installments on social media and
kind of the finesse of doing it and
wednes overload and um I had another
person who I'd met we were new friends
associates and all of a sudden I stopped
hearing from this person and about a
year or so later I got my answer and he
said that he didn't think I was a
genuine person that he thought
everything I was posting or tweeting or
whatever was to get me something was a
promotion now he's not in this industry
he's a nine-to-fiver on the East Coast
so I took that with a grain of salt
because I know that I pride myself on
not being overly yeah it's not for
everybody's taste and if so okay but I
didn't let his words affect me because I
was like you know what he's not in this
industry and he doesn't know he has some
friends that are actors in the biz
but they're very famous successful
actors and I said he doesn't get it that
those of us that aren't there yet really
have to do all the work that a publicist
and a manager and agent and you know a
street team and a fan club do you know
for the Charlie Sheen's and the you know
all the actors that are already out that
we have to do that allow ourselves but
it's hard um you just have to be
authentic like a note I hope that you're
being authentic but then your
self-esteem comes into play too
you